um um
[Music]
oh
uh
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
so
so
[Music]
mr
hello everybody
hello hello
we're going to get started thank you for
coming to other people's comedies
[Music]
if you would just don't have your cell
phones out refrain from
now coming to the stage we're going to
have a kill tony regular huh
[Applause]
hello give it up for the worst intro of
all time sam kuiper behind the desk
he's never done this before
oh hello
well thank you sam for nothing uh the
energy is totally dead in here
um
my name is oscar this is a dating show
we date each other you put your names in
a bucket and then you go on a date and
we watch you try to [ __ ] each other
uh we have a guest we always have a
guest like kill tony the show that i'm
ripping off right now
this guest is a female comedian very
funny from houston and has also spent
time in los angeles give it up for dulce
mac
it's dulce mac
have you been dulce
better
oh the mic is off
a classic blunder from sam kuiper sound
guy extraordinaire
hey i'm throwing it all on sam
the usual sound guy is supposed to be
here he's not here oh we got some [ __ ]
you sam
oh wait sorry
[Music]
that's really funny you defending
yourself from the sound board
really great
[Music]
it's great to be here
we're gonna watch people date how's your
dating life going i don't have one
that's probably good
i hear that uh in austin comedy there's
like a lot of a lot of drama going on
i don't hear anything about that okay i
just stay home
yeah i mean
[Music]
i uh i hate drama i don't date these
peasants
yeah comedians are gross
true a lot of them look like me
like losers do you're right that's
pretty gross we got one
lgbtqia plus in here i hope you're a
asexual cause you're just gonna be
dating yourself tonight
we only got one lgbtqia plus what a
freak
just kidding
i don't hate the case
i just called her a freak because
statistically speaking she is a freak
right now uh grant
is coming up
grandpa and josepha
our two friends in our friend group
give it up for grant
[Music]
yes
typical white dude on a date with
giuseppe
she's ethnically ambiguous
one minute and go
hi grant how are you hey joseph i'm
awesome what'd you do this weekend this
weekend yeah um
i cleaned and i did homework what did
you do
i should have cleaned and i should have
worked uh i was at the pool all day
yesterday actually
my pool which needs to be cleaned very
badly
by you or like is this like an apartment
uh yeah it's an apartment complex that
neglects all of their amenities so it
looks like
that algaeed up barton springs area
so it's like garden springs
yeah pretty much okay you like to go to
barton springs a lot yeah
when were you there last
last saturday
how many titties did you see
like
i saw one pair of today's so i guess two
when you see another woman's boobs do
you judge them like based off your own
and like critique them
oh do i compare myself to other women
yeah yes okay
now what was the talent like last time
like did you feel like it was getting
pretty heated out there in time give it
up for grants and giuseppa
he brought out titties and then took it
in the worst direction possible
that was so dumb grant
why did you bring up titties grant
um
troops are nice moves are nice
that's cool
giuseppo what are you ethnically
portuguese
you could throw a couple more italian
half okay
uh so uh how did you think that date
went with grant
it was
pretty mid
we already know each other so it's like
you guys have already established you're
not going to date each other we met on
this show this is like their third date
they're always here at the show
yeah which is often yes
so how did the first date go
i talked a lot
and she was a good listener
oh
[Music]
typical and her boyfriend was in the
audience oh yeah i was dating someone at
the time
a lot of people do that
well it made for a fun date uh yeah we
ended up having like a three-way date on
stage
oh yeah because my boyfriend came on
stage yes
i'd love to meet him
we're very open to experimental
couplings droplings
we're open to it all just as long as i
get to watch
but
so
grant
what's your body count dude
dude
it's a lie i don't even know
i lost my virginity when i was 17. i'm
26.
so less than 10 years let's go at an
average of three a year
three a year
you're gonna make us do math just yeah
three times
make some noise if you have a body count
higher than grant right now
oh yes oh yeah all the cool people
clapped all the losers were like i don't
have sex why would you
have sex it's like the only benefit to
living in a city
having sex yeah okay you have to [ __ ]
the people in it well sometimes you can
love
just kidding bringing up the concept of
love we all know that's hokum
yeah it expired in 1998 i have a theory
say more
before the internet and stuff
love's not real anymore
so you said you did homework and you
cleaned
so did you do homework and then you went
to work or do you just clean on your
free time
i was cleaning my apartment so i think
that's free time nice did you was it
messy like was it just normal cleaning
or was it a deep cleaning are you a
dirty person i'm a dirty person
gross yep grant how does that mean
well
i can clean somewhat but my dog he will
leave a bigger mess than anyone can ever
clean oh yeah what's your dog's name
ranger he sheds just constantly what
kind of dog is that
top okay a golden retriever
i was gonna make you guess like top
three shedding dogs and i
he is just to his frat dna it's like
what did you do stop dog i mean let's
play a little game guys
you're like a douchey joker
so uh what's like your favorite pickup
line like do you like to go up to girls
and be like guess the number between one
and ten i'm pretty terrible with pickup
lines honestly it has to be like you had
to be on the outside of a conversation
we're having so i'm like hey yeah what
do you think about racism or something
wow that's your favorite what do you
think about racism jessup
think about racism
what do i think about racism it's your
thoughts on racism controversial but you
know not not bad
just kidding very bad very bad super
super bad you
uh it's very bad uh what's the most
racist white dude
i
i definitely disapprove
of all racism last show y'all just like
asked me what's your favorite race and i
just like went ahead and just threw it
one round out and i won't do it this
time i won't do it what did you throw
out again nothing i said uh
myself something safe and boring it's
like latinas
or something it's situational you never
know what are your top three least
favorite races
i think that was literally the question
you asked me last time and i said the
answer and then that was what i'm not
gonna do this time healing the fifth on
this one just a reminder this is being
taped live on youtube yeah just get them
to say something embarrassing it could
potentially hurt their lives yeah grant
is growing
uh grant can you take your hat off
please
thank you
i just wanted to see something you can
put it back on
[Music]
put the hat back on guys
i have hair yeah i'm not
what you're not trying to
what was it what was the point of that
well he kind of looks like my ex with
the hat on but
the hat off doesn't help either so i'll
just accept it
you're getting strong x energies from
grand yeah
it means you love me once
so i'll take it have you dated lots of
white men before yeah
and what is your prognosis
on white men i like them they have lake
houses
i did used to have a i love japanese
used too grand has real lake face energy
like
what lake face
like face energy yeah i'm sticking with
it lake house
lake house face wrestling lakehouse face
did you own the lake house or was it
like a parent oh yeah totally a parent's
thing was it owned or rented it was
owned nice yeah well lake got that [ __ ]
lake cypress springs in northeast
texas okay
not tahoe or anything cool like that
unfortunately we weren't that rich what
did you do at this lake house that would
seduce a woman
oh
literally everything you can do on the
lake like take a girl out jet skiing
have you ever seen those like sea doos
yeah jet skis
like you're on stage with three
minorities i just want to make sure you
know britas
do you know clean water your privilege
is chilling
check your privilege dude
i'll take my privilege hat off you
really want yeah so you jet ski do you
own jet skis you used to those you know
what i'll tell you what happened to your
family what's going on
torn asunder by
controversial cheating and all sorts of
other uh
hbo documentary [ __ ] wow documentary his
parents [ __ ]
there's so much more to you
[Music]
yeah there's a lot under this hat but uh
what do you want to know
whose fault was it oh my gosh my dad's
your dad's fault but he's like you know
it takes two
yeah takes an enabler
i met grant's dad he's [ __ ]
weird
he's pretty he's cool to hang out with
and get drinks though he's got big like
type of personality
but then he comes home and
neglects his son and then his son
becomes
a fratty dude
he just keeps me downstairs while he's
got his mistress upstairs but uh grant
you're actually a very nice guy you know
you're not as douchey as your dad or my
ex
i appreciate it everyone in austin is
super nice
has not
hit someone yet
not yet
um but uh yeah
anyways uh giuseppe what do you think
about grant now
i think grant's really nice and i think
he's cute
what was the first do you think he's
freakishly tall
how tall are you like six four six four
yeah no i've dated taller no uh
because you don't want to be like shaq
with his girlfriend
you want to be like
sort of in the middle
you don't want to be like you know oh
yeah do you like tall women because i'm
not tall
my girlfriends have traditionally been
tall but i don't discriminate i will
date all kinds
indeed
i don't like it because when we're
walking down the street i can't hear
what you're saying
i can't is that why you guys always just
nod yeah
yeah
whatever
yeah anyways
um i
once had a girlfriend and she was really
hot
nice
what was your pick up line for her
uh
hi i'm open for kill tony
yes yeah message requests
ooh um
i don't know
i forget
um
it was online first you messaged request
you dm'd her
i usually meet girls because they
already know who i am and then i never
really meet girls in the wild like i
don't like it how would you approach a
girl in the wild
hey how you doing
works good
you uh
uh how about the uh austin fc i was at
the game earlier
hell yeah i'm so wet that was really
horny
i would do something like something in
the physical realm that we're in like
locally like oh did you see the asteroid
today or something to be like i'm not
just like in the
usa i'm i'm like here in the moment
okay
i'm so high right now yeah i'm sorry
so uh you said that uh there's a lot of
algae in your living
in your pool and you sweet swim in it
aside from
like
coveted
hiv and herpes it's full of like green
algae that lines the walls and people
still get in
it's just like watching people
it's turning into a swamp yes
it's like
in the texas heat all day
spoiling an ecosystem it's the grossest
thing ever like i expect shrek to walk
out any day now well i think something
if i asked would you jump in it
yeah i probably would honestly i'm
pretty easy to
bend my will into doing stuff for some
reason
he's a good soldier it's a weak
weakness yes that's the word uh i'm a
golden retriever as a half italian lady
do you see this as an opportunity to be
domineering and like take over
i'm half italian and half mexican so yes
oh nice
a mexicalian i think all my
ex-girlfriends have all been very
strong-willed people too so if they're
not like physically tall they're like
emotionally very tall like me
yes all women that are able to get up on
the stage probably like fit that bill
because they're confident in some way
have you ever
done something
aggressive and
you know domineering to
establish your protective zone
like
towards a male like
in what situation like a bar fight or
like a
confrontational situation yeah or
towards a female or towards a female
i've there i got roofied once
and uh i was apparently very aggressive
towards everything
so it's all like
strung together you're keeping it
together by being super nice yeah but if
you snap then it's like wow yeah the
frat hole comes out i'm so sorry you got
roofied that's [ __ ] blows yeah this
girl uh
gave me her drink at a bar
and it was a friend of mine so i just
took it and what i didn't know is she
was taking she got offered a drink from
a guy and then just passed it off to me
and i unknown targeted okay yeah she was
like like you know when they used to
poison kings they're just like
you try this first so i got fully
roofied and you got drive-by roofied
yeah
absolutely um
and i was apparently really like touchy
and stuff on my friends and that was
that was a rough night i don't remember
any of it but
yeah he was roofied
oh dude i was totally roofied
no that's cool i'm sure you're a roofie
that's a horrible experience uh
anyways
have you guys been a victim of crime
any felonies
like a victim of it or like
or a purpose i wouldn't have a felony if
i got because i've never been to jail
are you more mexican or italian i think
they both go to jail a good amount
would you go into the good jail or the
mexican jail
my great uncle died in jail because he
wouldn't snitch
so whichever one he was in are you sure
he just didn't speak english
i don't know if he spoke english so uh
have you ever been to jail
no have you been arrested no
boring why are you so good like are you
is that a thing no i just don't get
caught
congratulations grant have you ever been
to okay what's the craziest thing you've
done giuseppe
that you didn't get arrested for
very secretive
interesting i don't need was detained
once
what are you afraid is gonna happen
i don't know
because like i don't know what job i
want to do like long term so i need to
keep it open so you want to trick a
person into hiring you instead of being
honest you're tricking me
tell me later
anyways grant have you ever been
arrested when i was
13 uh
i got into like a stupid
little incident where we were ding-dong
ditching our neighbors
and i
thought it'd be cool to climb up
someone's house and see if i could look
in the window and apparently someone was
naked so they called the cops that's
such a white crime it is the widest
crowd i don't even know i was like dude
i bet i can climb that wall but you
can't you just have to go up one step
yeah i was already looking at their
window yeah pretty much so because
you're so freaky they caught me and well
i didn't get caught my friend got caught
and then he ratted on me
and then i got brought over and they
brought in the parents my dad smoothed
it out because he knows the art of the
deal or just getting out of crime i
guess
the art of the deal the art of the deal
that's the opposite of giuseppe's story
yeah it is literally grandfather was in
jail didn't snitch you don't snitch
that's so fake
you get snitched on
there's no saying for that
you just got to make good friends
well you know that's hilarious
you're just super funny you just saw
someone naked
it was an older woman and i was it was
like not worth it at all
not even she wasn't even hot man don't
risk me dude
unfortunate uh give it up for grant and
giuseppa
are good friends they went on a date
hopefully this one will stick
hopefully
they
become best
friends
we got charles
do we have a man named charles coming up
who is it sheila sheila
that's your friend yeah going on a date
with charles
bald man
wait did i say it wrong
shiloh shiloh i said it right earlier
charles give it up for them
let's give a little clapping welcome to
shiloh and charles
[Applause]
and go go ahead and talk to each other
so um i couldn't catch your name i it's
shiloh shiloh oh yeah so where are you
from shiloh i just moved here from new
york oh from new york yeah oh me too
really where from where in new york i
was in brooklyn oh okay i've been living
in jersey city okay yeah working in
manhattan how long have you been here
three months three months nice what do
you like about it i don't like it you
don't like it don't like it how long
until you go back
um i'm going back to new york in three
weeks oh and staying
maybe
okay
what don't you like about it out here
i mean what is there like about texas
the different vibes you're from brooklyn
i mean we're working in manhattan it's
totally different the people out there
are not as nice
the
i think it's been as hot but not in
winter
yeah but it's not winter it's going to
be
i think the problem with texas
is that people are polite but they're
not nice
right and time
give it up for shiloh and charles two
east coasters
meeting in texas
one is a happy refugee the other is
very critical of our abortion laws
what are you uh what do you like about
new york you're from brooklyn well i was
born and raised in new jersey but
just like him he's from jersey i'm from
upstate new york but i moved to jersey
you're the most new york guy ever
what do you do you're a garbage
collector you run numbers or for the
union you've run them things before but
yeah i know you look like it
like a cartoon of one
what uh how new york are you what's the
most new york thing that you do every
day
um
this is very un-new york of you you've
been yeah that's a hard question
there's so many things i do but i'm from
new york so it's all new york but
everybody does the same things i do
you know most people don't talk like you
right
yeah
i do know that it's just i was born man
that's not how you do it anyways shiloh
yes so jersey then brooklyn yeah what is
uh
what do you what do you represent
what does that mean that's very vague
like uh bushwick or oh bed star bedside
do or die or die
wow a real
brooklyn i so what do you think about
all these white people moving in
i mean
it's just weird texas is so weird
have you been here
the last three months the only guy i
went on a date with was from new york
i've heard the guys here in austin are
way worse but they are so bad i swipe
left 30 times before i swipe right true
well you know there's a different sort
of guy out here they're like more like
four tough you know like oh my god
[Laughter]
i had a truck pickup line on my bumble
for like a week
i was like if you have a truck let me
drive it yeah they don't like that what
are you moving they don't like that no i
just wanted to drive a truck you just
want to drive a truck
so
you you're from the east coast do you
think like the south is like
sort of
scary
no i don't really get scared of much
yeah
no well i mean they could be very
backwards in their marijuana laws and uh
lgbtq and abortion and
pretty much every major social issue but
besides that
the only thing progressive about texas
is no state taxes
hell yeah brother
that's the only part
yeah i mean uh some people
don't like texas it sounds like you
don't like [ __ ] i don't like texas
what are you here for are you here for a
job
no so my job i worked in tech recruiting
for uh yeah obviously a big tech company
so
i moved out here because i wanted to
leave new york for some time in my life
yeah i was like charles what uh what do
you do in austin
i'm just hanging out
hell yeah you're visiting
no i live here but
nobody pays me to do anything right now
and she's just hanging out
hanging out on a stoop
yeah
you know somewhere
an everything bagel
everything bagel those are good with uh
where were you doing 911
i was upstate i didn't move to down to
the city until 0-6
couch i was on the couch one night you
were watching it on tv like the rest of
us yeah
did you go and help clean it out
no no
not even helping at the end of it no
people that have yeah and they're all
dead now
you're not supposed to do that that's
like really dangerous apparently
uh dulce what do you think about this
new yorker have you ever been to new
york i have been to new york but i've
never met like a classic new york man i
know this is almost scary no i would
like to hang out with him just for a
while
are you sponsored by the bills
oh by the way excuse me by the bill
buffalo bills oh no that's my that's my
squad though for football that's your
squad
okay
are you gonna show us the game of three
card monty right now
i don't have that zombie but yeah
he's gonna sell us speakers under the
bridge under the i-35 overpass
so shiloh how long have you lived in new
york for
i lived in new york for nearly four
years
nice
so you graduated
from new york in the four-year program
they have there no i went to school in
new jersey oh nice yeah so what did you
like about new york
i mean it's disgusting but that's what
brings everyone together
yes
walking everywhere that's cool
pizza cool bagels bagels
hmm walking pizza and bagels hot men
everywhere dirty oh that's true
have you ever noticed hot men in new
york
um
yeah you know there's guys that are like
models good looking guys yeah what do
you say to them
you know judge why would you judge
no they're better looking than
like the other girl said she judges
her so by looking at other women oh yeah
that was that was a weird question
though yeah yeah it was but i think a
lot of us do that yeah totally i'm doing
it right now
no i will say from looking at titties
i'm just in the moment i'm not thinking
about my own
but maybe that's just me maybe you
should go to barton creek maybe you'd
like it there because there's a lot of
titties apparently yeah when you see
titties
what was this question that was such a
weird question
um what is have you ever been with a
woman are you bisexual i have wow
yes
that's hot
what uh clapping
yeah do you guys hate lesbians yeah it's
texas
you guys are proving all right
no this is a very lgbtqia plus friendly
crowd there's two lesbians right here
they're just here after brunch after
their afternoon carpentry session there
are u-hauls outside
so how did this bisexual encounter
happen
oh god are we really doing this only if
you want to
i mean
it's pretty simple i look like this
and then some woman was like holy [ __ ]
no
i'm not that easy i want to compare my
titties to her titties that's kind of
what happened
oh nice it was supposed to be through
some but the person that we're supposed
to be mutually hooking up with someone
bailed for a threesome
i was like i'll take a raincheck
i got more important things to do like
well three there might as well be two uh
there's too many people here
[Laughter]
wow what a loser charles have you ever
turned down a threesome before oh hell
no oh
charles would never do that
i don't know i've turned on threesome
threesomes how do you do that how do you
turn on a threesome
um
sometimes just being there
just exists
step number one exists
sometimes step number two i just go with
the vibes
he has a crystal my favorite type of
party is a swinger party
swinger party holy [ __ ] charles is a
freak
that's a joke
we had no idea and that's his squad
it's your squad bro you hang out with
leather daddies
they're there they are there
what's the most freaky thing you did
sexually
i mean everybody's got their own level
of freakiness but
i've been to swinger parties that wasn't
a joke that part wasn't a joke
okay
and did you bring a partner
no i was there by myself you just showed
up solo byog
yeah i got another [ __ ] you guys need
another [ __ ]
they do the wives show up
the wise they're just hungry for [ __ ] it
must be
were they attractive yeah
wow you went to an attractive swinger
party with a cop two of them there were
some definitely a few of them okay so
you had to pick and choose
i'm not that choozy
he's not that choosy he's from new york
he's not that choosy he sees good
looking guys all the time but
yeah
he just ignores them
so did you bang like some chicks that
you were like
wow this is the hottest girl at the
origin
yeah yeah
at the party
well you can say you did it did you have
to wait in line
um sometimes you have to wait was there
a line for you
was anyone waiting in line for i got
next
this guy's a real new yorker
i want some of that cannoli in me
without my knowledge maybe
they were waiting behind your back
have you so that's you had a bicep or
you had a lesbian encounter some dude
didn't show up you're like [ __ ] it yep
why not yeah why not
anyways
that's awesome yep
scissoring or 69 or how does it
however you want however you want
[Music]
what a wonderland no dulce what do you
think about this
this couple
well there's no passion
he just needs someone to go to the
swingers party with yeah i think they
need to that's not the most fun she
needs to find a crazy texas boy with a
truck and he needs to find a big booty
latina
yeah
that's another one
i mean i feel like i'm watching a buddy
cop movie right now oh my god
that was like that would be dope hell
it's like
beverly hills
cops but in new york so it'd be like
what's a hill in new york
no
murray hills in manhattan murray hill
cops
that's what it's like
so that's cool so you guys are both new
yorkers and you're here in texas
so you're when you when is your job when
are you looking to move back to
new york well i've only been here since
may
how long is your job for
i hope for a long time i mean i don't
want to lose my job
so
what do you what have you done in austin
so far is there something that you
didn't do like
terry black's
no i actually went to terry black's
thought i got food poisoning went to the
emergency room
and they got my gallbladder out
because that's why you hate austin
yeah well that was week two week three i
spent like two days in the hospital
terry black's indeed gall bladder
removal yeah maybe you should have gone
to chicago yeah yeah
maybe the deep dish is good
no it was a jalapeno sausage don't get
spicy sauce jalapenos damn it that's i
get that
well
well you know
there's a lot of great things in austin
you know zilker park have you been to
zilker park yeah yeah have you been to
barton creek yep
i'm out of stuff
i've done mount bono okay i was just
thinking that we're in sync that's hot
um i don't know what else you do here
yeah i also don't [ __ ] like it here
so i don't care
we all hate austin that city sucks
what's so good about austin it's
basically three streets divorce is
cheaper in texas
just we all know
hey
cheap divorce
so uh yeah
maybe you should go to um
bonnet bonnell mountbox
she's like i've seen views before i got
it i don't know why we gave you all we
could give you oh
gallbladder to enchanted rock
where that's cool
it's like an hour and a half away and
that's not austin
well
it's cool
but it's not here
what's the most funnest thing that
you've done in austin
probably see dulce
yeah first of all you haven't hung out
with me since we've been here i'm a
little offended how do you guys know
each other did i mispronounce your name
just now yes but i was reading it um
it's my second language um
yeah she doesn't care we met in new york
it was uh she knows my friend lizette
and they all go to the dog park together
and they have like dog park friendships
yes it's really cute
oh you have a dog that's adorable we
went to karaoke you went to karaoke
right yes we did yeah
nice can you sing
no okay
what's your dog like
he's very small
his name is sunny
i was lied to when i adopted him that he
was two and he's now six
miraculously so he's an old dog charles
do you have a dog i do not
what would you say if a girlfriend
brought home a dog and action
where did you get this dog from
and shiloh what would you say
like i had to get something that was
going to make me happy because this
obviously is not working oh
wow
so side question are both our names on
the lease
i just have a question
so this is what i say next this is when
you would walk out is what you're saying
that's kind of harsh
there's always you know there's a
there's a lot of ways to tell the truth
but to come home with a dog and say like
this is it maybe it's one of her
hilarious like a doberman hilarious
jokes
maybe she's just giving you a good old
new york riffing
what do you say in response to that
then i would laugh i'd have to know the
pretext to the you know you know how
it's been going previous weeks up
leading up to the dog purchase that's
where the acting comes in
that's where your imagination should
take over i like dogs though
he likes the what's the problem there is
no problem
congratulations
you guys did it
um but yeah what any uh any parting
words for shiloh to kind of sell
yourself
um
no not myself but i hope that she would
come back to texas at least because i
live here she's going to be here for a
while i live here you said you were
leaving well
i'm going to see my family and friends
well i hope you grow to love like it
more the best thing about
austin is other people a great way to
meet other new yorkers yes and kill tony
yeah
around a lot yeah
don't say anything you want to say to
your friend and the date that she went
on
i just hope you
get laid while you're here
okay that's that's a stretch that's why
i'm going back to new york but she's
like i need to go get late i'm going
back
i'm going back to you i hope it happens
tonight and it's spontaneous and maybe
in a public bathroom
live it up
wow
dulce i can't lay down in the bathroom
yes you can
they must be friends
not here you guys okay everyone
please
shiloh what do you have to say to
charles
um
i just hope that you get a dog that you
like
might not be for me but from like
your future mommy here in texas
because it's not it's definitely not
going to be me but you're cool i
appreciate it you're cool see
yeah maybe you guys could smoke a joint
later yeah our final
party
change your flat tire together or
something
give it up for a shiloh and charles
they're definitely not gonna [ __ ] each
other apparently
what a bummer what a waste of time that
was
uh we got one more man or a lot more men
coming out we got hollis
jen
we got these names that are all
scratched scrushed up
i don't know what that means but i'm
picking one of you next so it didn't
work whatever you were doing
we got hollis going on a date with jen
oh my god these guys came together
that lady shook it really vigorously
we're getting help from the audience we
got a date coming up with hollis
and the other person that got picked and
go
hello
what up how you doing
good how are you i mean i feel like we
already went through all this
yeah i mean because we already knew we
should we actually worked together and
[ __ ] so it was like
but uh
okay yeah so you know i guess reiterated
what you've been up to
i
started a new job a couple months
ago it's really cool
yeah you said it was you said it was
something yeah
work in space tech yeah um i'm not a
rocket scientist or anything like that
um but yeah i do training for sales
teams
that's still dope though you know you
said something about like you know if
you were lost in the woods
you would be able to kind of like geo
track here
well i said it but i mean you know it
was a
inference based on what you said but you
kind of said like you could kind of do
that you just couldn't get the
directions right like yeah i mean
yeah i mean i i wouldn't use that
wouldn't be like my trusted source to
like
get if you ever lost in the woods gin
can help you end time give it up for jen
and hollis
jen the human compass
and hollis
a person who's already done this before
on the date
uh so how did you guys meet um we used
to work at a company called maitreet hub
and we sold social media management
did you know that she had a new job
i did not well actually i did today
because she told me and then also you're
like i haven't seen you for a while yeah
it's like hey what you been up to she's
like oh i was in california for a little
bit and doing my thing and i was like
okay i've been you know it's funny doing
my stuff and you're like
i want to go on a date with you but i
don't really notice if you're gone for
two months
i mean yeah fair enough you can't really
uh go on a excursion with somebody in
the city
without
them being there so i agree
okay i uh he's trying to communicate
with me speaking autism yes a little bit
a little bit like a slice of autism in
there [ __ ] is this how i talk yes are
you mocking me see
see we're here we go brothers in the in
the speech game okay
i feel like we're gonna [ __ ] dude
i mean can you go i don't
get the [ __ ] out of here
no we're just kidding
um
jen uh how did you how did you first
meet hollis
um
at work same place yeah
main street hub yeah basically we were
at main street hubs
yeah she was in the cubicle area and i
was in a cubicle area and uh
did she touch her cubicle area uh
neither one of my cubicles would have
touched no yeah
but
that being said like it was she was
chill she seemed pretty chill she seemed
pretty cool
uh i feel like we talked about something
maybe it was marvel or something i don't
know something like that i was like oh
i'm kind of into that you know and then
uh yeah a couple years went by
and uh
yeah i was like hey what's up let's go
hang out you know nice
catch up you know
yeah so you guys work together you guys
are both professionals you have jobs i'm
like that guy from new york who's just
come here to hang out
i mean i don't have a job job but he
doesn't contribute to our economy
yeah you know you got to contribute
something either buying or spending
because capitalism is horny for money so
oh my god you're such a bummer dude no
one wants to hear about capitalism we're
at a dating show that's true that's true
i mean the last guy talked about a
swinger orgy he was uh yeah
okay i mean you know that's cool
orgy oh i agree with you
completely
um jen you said you
you trained the sales force at a space
science company in space no um so i work
for a company that has their own fleet
of satellites and we
image earth and we sell that data
so i train the sales team give it up for
google earth yeah
yeah she's
contributing to the
sum of human knowledge
well
we're out here delivering uber eats for
each other
hey you know thomas has a more
interesting job than i do
hollis what do you do are you in the
salvation army
uh i was in the marine corps but it
wasn't like salvation involved but yeah
but uh no i was i'm an actor that's my
main
main shebang oh nice you're a famous
actor
uh perhaps if we're living in like a
past present future type of you know
scenario in our existence then yeah can
you uh give us a little example maybe a
little hamlet maybe a little macbeth a
little macbeth a little hamlet
uh i could give you uh i could give you
a pulp fiction
how about
one
one word from pulp fiction
one word
as long as you're squished together
right sure
[ __ ]
give it up for hollis a professional
actor
he just acted in front of your faces i
acted so hard right now
i could feel it in my jelly right that's
a thing in the black community right
acting hard acting hard yes it is you
know you concentrate all your acting
juices into one area and let it marinate
and then you you start pooping out some
you know
some stuff
metaphorical poop if you will
a professional actor
yes this is how he thinks of his craft
yes this is my this is my my craft this
is how i get jack
so he we just saw hollis act up act up a
storm right now can you like sell us
something
and go
[Music]
hi hi
that's step number one
it's like an orgy step number one exists
sell that chair or okay
in one word sell that lollipop
so this lollipop um
it's uh
a tropical flavor
oh look at that it's a lot of words you
know what tropical flavors do
what they do
it's also made in mexico so yeah
i mean you can do this you have
commercial experience
i mean oh that's a smart move make him
sell himself
yeah you know uh supervisor is the most
important step bounces as they say
uh let's see what we got we got a uh
she's delegating earth
pop organic okay so look you like
suckers all right in any form do you
like suckers or whether metaphorically
literally with a sucker something
involving fellatio do you like it well i
guess i'll tell you this all the kind of
suckers you used to is extremely
unhealthy for you okay it's [ __ ] you
up either interning this is like a
commercial something like yeah you know
it's
got a great voice it the
washington voice i thought
oh the oh hold up you gotta then say you
gotta be like you gotta be like uh
you
you mother
you dis loyal
[ __ ] made [ __ ] don't do this to me
to me you got you got to get that point
in there
i don't know what scene that is
it's been training i haven't seen that
one uh training king kong ain't got [ __ ]
on me oh he's looking like you're
transported
you know that movie yeah you know he's
always like a little confused but he's
got conviction and she's like
it's like we're watching the movie right
now you know i don't gotta love you just
get you myself transported to this
i'm supposed to protect you
what is
what is like the craziest role that
you've had
craziest craziest role um
i guess
i had to
well
i guess craziest i had to be this guy
who was selling meth like trash meth
uh in order to pay for these experiences
you only sell good meth oh you know
normally it's only good [ __ ] and i'm son
but i'm i'm a moralist so but you're
like heisenberg from breaking bad yeah
heisman met the white people drug though
i mean i don't take it i'm just saying i
sell it to white people you know what
i'm saying but profiting it's probably
for the whites
you have
black hair
uh so what uh what asian are you um
i don't know guess
thailand no
vietnam no
mexico
close
philippines lot of ideas there we go a
filipino so do you have a thing for
asian women hollis
i mean i don't really discriminate you
know i'm more of a uh
how you call it proximity type of dude
so just you know
geographically satellite you know where
wherever i'm at then whatever is coming
to me the easiest low-hanging fruit as
we say in sales
uh nice that's that's what's gonna be
you know i'm not out here you're like uh
you're like a honing missile that was
the worst sailboat
of all time
that was that was the perfect
you're doing great i don't want a
[ __ ] dude that says he's good with
this not every single person
yeah well the thing is you gotta call
everyone a good fruit well the thing is
the fruit that hangs the lowest even
like in actual real life it usually has
has
sometimes can be the rightest that's all
that's really doing
how does this make you feel
um
you know i i think i'm pretty secure
with myself so
well
don't you think hollis was kind of
low-hanging fruit meaning he was like
the most ripe you know in real life
low-hanging fruits are the best you know
all the sugar pro tip you get a
pineapple flip it upside down for a day
overnight maybe it comes out sweeter
swear to god yeah
what does that mean in this metaphor
though um well you know maybe if you
flip your perception of what you believe
you want when that hasn't had a track
record of working perhaps uh you will
find a sweeter result so you want to go
to a swinger's orgy right now yes i love
swings so well i know a guy from new
york he can help you out okay [ __ ] i got
extra bedroom i'm like yo i'm trying to
get like a swing and a trampoline but i
got ceiling issues so
but you know
okay i think we did another scene from
training day that was yes part two
training
training jen what do your parents think
about you being on a date with a black
man are they typical asian parents or
are they
progressive filipinos i mean we're just
hanging out
right
hanging chilling swinging
swinging we can they're actually i don't
know if that's racist or perverted
maybe
i mean i i
i would say on the scale of one a racist
with where my filipino immigrant parents
are at i would say
about a six
so you know not like
all the way
but uh yeah they're generally racist
yeah like they'll probably see my
picture and be like
ew
hmm yeah this guy's
this guy looks like his dick is too big
i mean you know the doctor said you know
the doctor said what did what did the
doctor say i used to have a and i
actually don't have a belly button right
and so this
are you adam you can't just drop that
and not explain
the main point of the thing is that how
are you born were you born in a test
tube
i mean maybe i mean my mama ain't
telling me some [ __ ] but all i know is i
had to see your belly or lack a belly
button it was they chopped it off is
what i'm saying and so oh yeah but
apparently if i had let it grow it would
have also engorged my penile area
yeah that's more my belly button that
ate your penis essentially what doctor
did you go to uh uh dr steve and them in
dallas stephen m and dallas doing some
texas
medicine yeah you know yeah if you don't
cut the belly button off
yeah
it'll turn it'll eat your penis
yes save the dick no texas has very fine
medical institutions and we support
baylor university baylor's cool i think
i went to dallas presby so medical
what is this called what is this thing
that eats your dick called oh i think
it's just called like an enlarged navel
so like and i don't think it actually
eats your dick i was just joking about
me maybe i don't know but anyway
god it just uh it's just a big ass belly
button you know what i'm saying so they
just cut it off
uh that's real the joke being i was like
oh it you know makes your dick much
bigger it's like but seriously though
how they cut it off how does it make
your dick bigger if you cut your belly
button off
oh i mean i don't know if all the
dick juices was absorbed in the belly
button and eventually over time it was
it was gonna like i would have had like
a six incher as a baby so that would
have been a problem so he had to cut it
off and it was like all right
your dick was six inches as a baby it
would have been like i said we're
talking about past present future time
and stuff it would have been i have no
idea how did they not cut it off but
they cut it off so
now it's just like a normal uh
i'll say modestly uh above the
statistical average penis
uh holy [ __ ]
i think that was the that was the thing
for black panther three we just heard
sun pics
how big is my penis
jen
with the question of the day
as an asian man
my penis is above average there you go
hey to be fair i did volunteer my
tangent i'm american average 5.5 inches
that's what i'm willing to admit to
that is apparently the uh the average
they like officially was like
that's that's it
it's called math yeah
what uh what school did you go to
juilliard
nah uh nothing like that i knew a girl
named julie but
no when i was like in
high school i went to
conrad in dallas and then marcus
in uh a place called flowers so i
basically moved in and out the suburbs
like you went to a school called flower
flower mound
actually it was called marcus but it was
in flower mountain texas i should say
so hell yeah oh somebody you know yeah
texas baby
what do you have to say yeah
yeah marcus smart i knew that dude he
i thought he was good uh
but i didn't know he was that good i
mean i don't watch sports like that i
was animated at the time but we was like
one of them animated anime i was in
anime and me marcus my my homie rufus in
an anime what does that mean
no i'm i was into anime oh so you
weren't into sports yeah i played sports
which is how i knew marcus but uh yeah
so this is some famous guy
apparently apparently he plays for some
basketball uh
yeah he plays for boston uh the
basketball player so what do you have to
say to uh shiloh
who says that austin ain't [ __ ]
um you know it's
i guess it depends on what you're
comparing it to what do you compare it
to
dallas
and how does it stack up
i'll say
i appreciate growing up in dallas
because it's like pretty multicultural
like i said i was in and out of the
suburbs that's nice you learn a lot but
as an adult if we could just somehow i
don't know like reverse osmosis
gentrification or some [ __ ] here or i
don't know just get more black folks
here and other ethnicities
that i wouldn't have any other issue
with austin quite frankly aside from the
prices and [ __ ] dallas is also cheap
yeah you whites look how many whites no
just kidding we love the whites which
yeah i'm like i love everybody really
but it's just like it's nice growing up
in dallas like that literally every kind
of
person is around you're just like oh
yeah okay but austin is great in other
ways
yeah but it's great in other ways it's
like a lot more chill i like the
magazine
the domain yeah that's the you know
domains
that's for richard
expressway expressway
uh
h-e-b-a i guess they have we you can
smoke weed here somewhat
somewhere freely you know what i mean
because you can't really do that in
dallas so
i like cali too though if it wasn't so
expensive as well
i agree with you
yeah
and i propositioned to jen
how long have you lived here
i have lived here for 10 years in austin
wow
originally for from the bay area of
california yeah i won't talk about yeah
are you from the bay area was that a bay
area yell
no i was you know that one time
is that why you yell when
a gay guy
walks by
uh
jen uh
what do you like about austin that
you've lived here a decade
um
okay so she hates it i
i i
don't think texas is better than new
york i've been there once
and i don't think we all know this
we can all see a graph
new york has a lot more cool stuff
we're here because we couldn't make it
there
stop reminding us i mean like i love
austin i mean i i love the weather here
i i love hot weather
jen
likes a good sauna she does hot yoga
i do you do hot yoga is that weird as a
filipino um no i mean if i feel like i'm
in my natural state
in a hot room humid
is the best
do people fart in hot yoga i'm sure they
do
you do hot yoga
no
that's always been my fear i like yoga
and stretching and [ __ ]
but i hate farts you're afraid of farts
and hot yoga i am i'm seriously not
scared of many things but like a
well-timed fart near my face i'm jumping
you know what i'm saying like i just
don't like anyway so if it's humid
that's like a you can slice through that
you know what i'm saying like oh and
then i see a movie for you instead of
snakes on a plane it could be farts in a
yoga room oh my god that would i would
much rather the snake way too many farts
in this [ __ ] yoga room goddamn yogurt
[ __ ]
yes exactly
dulce you're in the performing arts what
do you think about this actor
i don't know what hollis said this whole
time i don't know what he's talking
about
they don't have black people in
venezuela and we do
um
and i'm from houston
h town until i die
so he was like i'm from dallas and i was
like i'm not listening anymore oh yeah
there's that's the old thing dallas
versus houston no but i feel like uh
we would be cool but we would argue
most likely but i like to uh i think
it's fun if you not necessarily argue
but if you're just like going back and
forth and [ __ ] you know it's like
you're forcing yourself to look at your
own perspective in the other persons and
be like all right let's let's figure out
some kind of truth in here you know see
you turn a five-minute argument to an
hour one i already know yeah no yeah my
ex is exactly what happened
that's exactly what happened hollis
what's the last argument that you got
into with the significant other
oh god let's just argue with him he's
thinking of specifics right now
the very last one
oh okay well i guess with my ex the last
one i remember that was prolonged was
about
plastic surgery i think
oh [ __ ] yeah please stop it's been about
[ __ ] like sandwiches i would love to
hear a man's perspective on this am i
right ladies
oh wait no
her her thing was like we were chilling
i was smoking and you know i was playing
with the cat and
you're like babe you should get your
face done
no it was hideous she so it was quite
amazing he was against it yeah i was
i was actually yeah i wasn't i was
against it but even then i wasn't like
against it it was just like she was like
oh man you know
most of those most everybody in uh that
is famous
has plastic surgery
and i was like i don't think that's true
jen do you think that's true i think
that's true oh [ __ ] round two
so then we proceeded and i'm like okay
so do you mean like literally everybody
or you just saying like ah you know like
most people in hollywood they probably
got something done i'm like i could kind
of see that for sure but that was the
result of this argument uh
eventually
she started getting upset because
like
yeah she just started getting upset
essentially like upset cause she i think
she was relating it to something
else more personal which again before
they even happened i had already brought
the fact it was like hey i'm not saying
that literally like using my sister for
example if she got famous she wouldn't
get plastic surgery just for a fact so
factually if that's if that's how you're
trying to say it then that's incorrect
but she was like starting to relate to
like personal [ __ ] and like
funny anyway funny enough a couple days
later she kept she was chilling she was
like
oh me and one of my best friends is
coming she's coming
sorry i smoked before this oh my god
anyways that was a great
way to end this story
jen what do you think about this debate
do you think you could be with a guy
that just like argues about plastic
surgery out of the blue
um oh my god
that's why um i don't know i mean i i
feel like a woman should do whatever she
wants her body
and if yeah wallace doesn't support that
then well no here's the but here's the
thing here's the [ __ ] up part i did
support that i even said in the argument
i was like yo i think that everybody
should be able to do what they want to
do she wants i don't care she was just
trying to say this is think of
celebrities in whatever way she wants to
which is cool
arguing semantics what was she wanting
to hear
she basically wanted to hear did i oh
you're right
no not even that because i already said
she was attractive like i was like
like maybe first off everybody's beauty
standard is different so even if i say
you're attracted doesn't matter as long
as you think you're attractive yourself
right
but that being said
like yeah i think you're attracted so
say if you wanted to get positive
surgery i wouldn't say you need it don't
say what do you think do you think like
this is way too much arguing like do you
feel like you would argue with him or
now more or less no like if it's not
something i care about i'll just be like
yeah you're right
and then i wouldn't even talk anymore
because i'm like well that's what's the
[ __ ] point you just because i don't
want to argue about stupid stuff what is
not arguing though isn't it people are
oh my god he's actually arguing with her
about arguing it's just exploring an
idea it's like all right cool you you
think this i think this i'm like i don't
really
care about happiness
how did you figure that out how did you
figure out that you would argue a lot i
just know i know
you know she probably experienced
similar like personality types he was
like oh this [ __ ] likes to like argue
and [ __ ] about whatever
but what's your hot take what's your
hottest take hottest take
hottest take
i mean i don't know like like my own
personal of actual opinion on something
or just like just say something crazy
right now
okay uh you know i think that uh
is possible that if you
if you wanna
yeah if you wanna do whatever you wanna
do it's possible in some like you know
somewhere in the multiverse you can do
anything you want to do
yeah
okay theoretically or hypothetically i
guess yeah you could do whatever you
know what a hot take is
oh you talking about like some awesome
ass or like like abortion or some [ __ ]
okay abortion i think that everybody
should be able to again do whatever they
want to do with their body getting
abortion
i i actually i think it's out actually
angers me because i don't want to be
told what to do with my body so
somebody's like oh you you what do you
think about muslims
uh
so i think muslims are chill i think
that the religion itself is also gets
kind of a bad rep because to me i'm not
religious so most religions have some
sort of violence in it read the
[ __ ] ultimate oh my god you're
like an anti-hot take machine you find
the best things out of everything
i don't i don't know those are my takes
on this one like i don't really have any
strong opinion like the only thing i
have like a strong opinion on is like
what you're sorry
what is your philip what is your
filipino parents hottest take
oh yeah
what would your filipino parents say
that would shock this liberal white
audience
i don't know
okay
they'll say filipino came
before spanish
i don't know they're similar the
language
i mean they have similar words so that
would be a hot take that they could take
yeah we have like a lot of the like
basic
words that are the same you're a great
asian daughter protecting your parents
like that
i don't talk to my mom
whoa
why not what happened you know it's
those uh toxic asian mother-daughter
relationships yeah she's like you're
working at a space tech company you
should be a space doctor
space lawyer
she wanted me to be a nurse that's like
a thing when you're filipino like they
all want you to be nursing during the
middle of a pandemic also your parents
want you to be a nurse i thought that
was just because like maybe they were
nurses like you should be i mean my dad
doesn't care what i do i mean he cares
what i do but he's more supportive of my
own he's more american
yeah
that's nice
at least she got one you know yeah i got
one on my side yeah
i'm sure that hollis what do you think
about filipinos
uh i mean like they're tight one of my
best friends ryan is half filipino uh
ryan heckler shout out bro uh but uh
yeah he's pretty chill his mom made us
the egg [ __ ] is that duterte
yeah it's like uh
it's kind of it's kind of like you're
aborting it like you can see all the
that's why i'm proportional you're
eating some of the feathers and like
they love it in salt it's
i've had it once when i was a child and
my
flavor profile could not handle it um
but yeah it's uh
if you ever go to the philippines it's
interesting to try
yeah but yeah the filipinos are cool
they're cool yeah what do you think
about manny pacquiao
he's cool i think that um
he could have
i think he definitely could have beat
mayweather and when i was watching it i
didn't really have any i was like ah
whatever i like them both but damn you
you're saying manny pacquiao is a [ __ ]
you're saying that filipino pride man
you gotta [ __ ] him up
[ __ ] up many
anti-filipino we finally found a hot
take there you go there you go i hate
supporting manny pacquiao so we'll watch
it is the one filipino friend that you
have the only filipino person you know
other than me uh no actually i know a
lot of my homie claire we actually uh
met dave chappelle together randomly uh
claire randomly where uh famous filipino
name
uh right here
claire hugo well i should say anyway
clear here you go well there you go but
uh sounds wet as [ __ ] it was at the uh
would you call it the paramount moa mare
was performing was like his first
performance or whatever so
she's not the only filipino that you
know she's not your only peanut oh not
my only pee though i i i definitely know
several pinots myself you know what i
mean like
peanuts
pinot gris yes uh yeah pinot noir
anyways let's get one more couple up
here
it's hollis and jen
thank you guys so much for going on a
date in front of us and in real life
yeah art imitates life
we get one more couple up here it might
be you
i'm going to do one of the scrunched up
names i don't know what this is
this is a dark soul whoever it is leah
leah
here she comes
i
know we got marcus
bay city
marcus bay city here he comes his
friends out at him too
give it up for marcus bay city
emilia
wow
and uh what is her name leah leah thank
you for joining us tonight
thank you for having me
just got back from an easter egg hunt
uh give it up for marcus
and leah
and go
hi
how are you i'm uh i'm okay
yourself i'm good thank you where are
you from
bay city oh
bay city where are you from i'm from
austin yeah how long you've lived in
austin all my life it's like 30 years
yeah a lot of partying no no not a lot
of party that's what i do when i come to
austin i mean are you visiting i'm not
from here i'm from uh bay city's like
near the coast so but are you visiting
austin right now are you living i just
moved to new braunfels like three weeks
ago so i'm just
getting to know the area okay but uh we
used to come up here all the time it was
like family and [ __ ] okay yeah but um
what do you do for work i do photo and
video work i'm like a freelancer okay
yeah
a gypsy
do you like it
it's all right
yeah what do you do i'm an attorney
oh [ __ ]
i feel like i got to watch myself now
like end time give it up for marcus bay
city
and leah
marcus what did you do in bay city
smuggled drugs
yes he actually got it right he's a drug
smuggler talking to an attorney
mushrooms yeah
do you have any legal advice you'd like
to ask leah right now maybe about a
pending charge i don't do pro bono work
hell yeah charges
you're gonna have to pay for this legal
advice marcus bay city i think i got it
under control now
you got it he's like legit nervous right
now
his remember this is going out on
youtube
what's about youtube we're you're on
youtube right now anything you want to
admit to anything you want to tell us
you want to get off your chest
not today
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is going on why is this
guy just asking vocabulary questions
just google it
pro bono
are you trying to make a boner joke
yes she was saying
she's not oh bro
are you on a date who's your date
oh god holy [ __ ] you guys are autistic
as [ __ ]
where did you guys meet
netflix
they're your friends yeah yeah oh my god
you brought all of bay city with you and
your toxic energy bay city needs to sit
down
thank you thank you what is happening
dude are they defending you do they
think that you're under attack
thank you
what's with your friends marcus what
what's his name
well that's actually my cousin okay
bay city cousin um she was just saying
she's not gonna answer legal stuff right
now so can you stop giving it more
attention okay
okay yes i feel like i'm in bay city
right now me too and a trailer park
what do you mean bro bono it's like oh
[ __ ] am i gonna get jumped is this what
paparazzi feels like
right outside for me
what is something that you would like to
ask an attorney if you had
if you had the opportunity to um
i guess uh i do have a couple questions
about
um how long did you go to school for i
guess
god damn you're trying to [ __ ] your
attorney maybe that's why you get in so
much legal trouble dude
like did you get it done in eight or was
it
undergrad is four years law school is
three years and i took two bar exams so
plus two more years
yeah seven nine nine years nine years
yep
how much schooling do you have marcus
schooling
yeah
i don't really like school
this girl loves school so much she went
to school for nine years
can you imagine that can you imagine
you'll be like i need nine more years of
this did you go to school
yeah dude
i wear glasses i don't i'm not from bay
city
i would die over there
your friends just about killed me right
now
marcus uh how much schooling have you
done if any uh no i i went to um like
the army so they taught me a little a
little bit
the army school yeah it was kind of
grunt grunt work so you're a veteran
yes but i didn't give it up for a member
of our armed forces a veteran marcus bay
city
home of the veterans i don't like saying
that [ __ ] i didn't i never went overseas
or anything so i can't really well you
got to explain the gap in your
schooling somehow schooling
i don't really need school though i'm
just
i'm all talent
okay
i mean this girl did nine years of it so
yeah maybe you don't want to tell her
that yeah i think there's just different
um we have we're in different fields
no way
i totally had no idea
i thought you guys are from the same
neighborhood the same suburbs yeah
no just kidding
what do you think about this uh romeo
and juliet capulet and
the other one
donahue
whatever i don't know the names yeah
the last names
i mean you guys both look mexican but
she's like the good mexican and you're
like
the bad mexican i'm persian
oh [ __ ] you mean good like as in like
good and bad as in
as in like criminal and like law abiding
yeah
let's take a step back she's not a
lawyer
this is a trap we got him boys okay i
guess it kind of a kingpin a bay city
yeah it kind of got awkward for me i'm
not really like
um like a criminal i'm a big criminal
yeah you're a veteran but i'm making a
joke because your friends are ratcheting
yeah yeah but
i did um
you caught me off guard with the
smuggling [ __ ] because i did get caught
with 100 pounds of weed yeah we know
dude that's badass you could it's like
the underground railroad except i was
just trying not like supplies my own
habit really was the problem and
sorry
this is going out on youtube
marcus
i feel like everything was damned up
pretty well and now you're kind of
letting it slip yeah yeah well look i
got a lawyer now so i think we're good
oh no no no
he does not like you why don't you like
marcus he's a lovable criminal i don't
do criminal cases what do you do with
your expensive law degree energy law
energy law
some guy just came right now she just
gets cooler
i said you get cooler the more you thank
you energy law
what's your favorite energy law
my favorite energy law yeah like a law
that you're like what man that's a good
piece of legislation
oh
hmm
i don't know i got to think about it
what about the clean air act well i do
transmissions so like i help build power
plants so no clean air here
nice what does that mean
why are you guys whistling is she only
she's a bad cleaner
oh it's bad air
power player what are you what are you
using yeah thank you so i'm doing my job
yeah
you're protecting the people that keep
our lights on yeah in the ac what uh
what do they burn for fuel
oh i don't know you gotta ask the
engineers that i just deal with the
contracts
um the contract lawyer for an energy
firm
hot marcus have you ever met one of
those before
usually i just walk out of the date
whenever that [ __ ] comes you've never
met a lawyer before disrespectful no no
i just um i just know we're not going to
click so i'm not going to waste my time
i'm going to waste her time
well i'm sure leah does fun things you
know like i'm sure you guys both love to
you know
go fishing or
no
i will say if after five minutes i'm not
like
i know if it's going to work out or not
so i also leave i don't know i think
marcus
doesn't even want to [ __ ] me i mean he's
not oh come on yeah sorry if you want to
be on stage you want to [ __ ] hans that's
the only way he's just nervous
i just feel like a lot of nervous energy
i kind of got put on the spot i didn't
know my name got dropped in the bucket
oh
he did this too
do you want to get your friend up here
to go on a date with leah leah
i think he's ready okay the protester
yeah
honestly i think you want me to pick
another name it'd be a good deal
pick another name i don't want to go out
with the protester no not the protester
i'm also scared um
so if we could keep him well we only
have zero more minutes left let's just
get him up here and get out of here we
got cassandra going up on the date
cassandra that's her that's your friend
going on a date with your friend no
that's my friend that's your friend yeah
cassandra
let's go cassandra
bye
you outed your friend now she's outing
you going on a date with your friend
what's your friend's name
oh he's coming up here yeah
yeah he signs you up
he needs to go up cause he signed you up
i thought i was gonna hit two for one
tonight what's your friend's name
was this the accountant in the gang
no way oh don't do that
there are stairs you know how she came
up here you could have done that
oh my god he touched me
all right are you ready cassandra
cassandra
oh my god cassandra going on a date with
the what's your name
noe
and cassandra starting now
nice to meet you cassandra it's
cassandra nice to meet you too oh i i
like i like your face i think you're a
pleasant person
um
now if you could please give me some
compliments go ahead
if i had one i'd say it damn
damn maybe you start off bad oh oh i
love you go ahead
how did you meet or sorry that was your
cousin not your friend
right
yeah okay so what brought both of you to
austin
we were very bored we woke up this
morning we spent the entire last
spl spinning playing mario kart and we
woke up
and we're like [ __ ] it let's go to
austin
i'm i'm like i'm being dead as serious
okay that's how we end up here
today america is a great country
there's not a lot of countries you could
do to like wake up in the morning and
time
give it up for noe thank you a real
proponent of our interstate system
and cassandra
a very distinguished
woman
who hangs out with lawyers
well i'm i'm
knowing we're not talking to you right
now
don't mind my business
give it up for the kid from up if he
grew up and
became schizophrenic
and made a lot of money made a lot of
money what did you make a lot of money
in
telling folks how to pay the taxes
you're an accountant
a good one so you spend a lot of time
behind a computer or oh yeah paper you
don't really get out much and talk
my glasses are the ones that um have the
blue lens behind it and how much
accounting do you do in bay city
not a lot not a lot i'll be honest with
you
we got out of bay city pretty quick
where the [ __ ] is bay city i've never
heard of this place
they take advantage of a lot of people
that don't know a lot about the things
and if you don't know a lot about
anything they just
whip the the [ __ ] lash on your ass
and
what the [ __ ]
is this the swingers orgy that you were
at
no one knows what you're talking about
dude i'm gonna be honest with the
ambiance i i stared into your eyes and i
lost my train of thought
i mean really that's what happened to me
i feel like that happens to you a lot
yeah
i i i couldn't take it serious anymore
no how do you like your big trip into
the city
are you excited to go back here what the
[ __ ] you said i'm gonna be i'm confused
how are you how are you enjoying this
trip so far because you're not from here
you're from a small little town where
nobody really i live in new brunswells
like i i moved out a little bit oh you
just completely threw me off
what is this
is this how you talk in new braunfels a
little is this a new brothel's accent
no no this was i mean just say straight
up but like
no wait how did you meet your girlfriend
come home
oh [ __ ] nobody's about to say something
crazy right now
a lot a lot of [ __ ] starch a lot of
storage sorry you know what i'm talking
about you know what i'm talking about
he doesn't know what i'm talking about
you better start no one knows what
you're talking about
noe you're going off the rails a little
bit
okay okay okay
how about i'm a little drunk
yeah you should not drink
have you ever
what were you like in high school oh oh
i i i won
mr bchs was mr bay city high school
student
i won a lot of [ __ ] i was really good in
in high school is this what football
players look like in bay city
well
i wasn't i wasn't the best football
player but i was i was a good talker i i
knew how to maneuver around the
the city and i knew how to do my thing
what did you maneuver into what is the
most biggest thing that you maneuvered
into
you you see how i know how to pause he
everybody they [ __ ] love that no he's
very self-aware right now
i think they're laughing at you not with
you
nobody knows what
nobody's met anyone like you before okay
okay
you are unique
what have you used your smooth talking
abilities to get
besides your beautiful girlfriend
you guys are perfect for it i think that
may jeopardize that so let's let's just
let's calm down like you don't you don't
[ __ ] with
let me we're not [ __ ] we just want to
know how a guy like you
gets laid
oh oh okay okay okay okay
i'll let me you just keep going for it
just keep going for i was a salesman
above all
like you just keep going for it going
for it go that girl thinks it's funny
she thinks it's funny she thinks this
guy is counting
people
no no now that i'm on stage of course
it's hard because if i get off oh you're
doing great noe no you're you're doing
you're getting a lot of laughs
aren't you happy why don't you count
your laughs again
maybe that'll make you happy you know
what the worst thing is like i i know
you won't kill tony i've seen you won't
kill tony a lot you you are i mean i if
i thought
maybe i'm wrong you may be seeing me
within yourself with what you have been
on kill tony i don't think i've ever you
have not been the most charismatic
individual i don't kill tony at all and
you you kind of get it
maybe i don't think i've ever done what
you're doing right now i'll kill tony
it pisses me off because i'll never be
that funny
i would never i and then it was a
natural with that being said don't look
into my eyes
girlfriend to get the hair color that
you have no one i don't
i can do whatever the [ __ ] i want first
of all and i'm trained in boxing so if
you want to go outside and box let's
[ __ ] go cause no way no one wants to
live my name is life
no way no one wants my hair looks hot
everyone here thinks so and if no one
thinks so they're dead
they know that
no way
anybody may need to learn the first rule
of roasting is uh pick your battles
okay okay okay cassandra what do you
think about this character are you ready
human
cartoon i think i'm hallucinating
sam i think i've never been on a date
like this before never
what would you say to him if you were
out in the wild
and this was an actual date you were at
like speakeasy or like
i i think i'd be scared i would just
leave
okay
may i see something
you you have never been around a
individual that could pay for your date
yes yes i don't know i don't know if
you've been
around
with
seventy dollars in the bank account
what have you said that shows me you can
pay for an afternoon
i am a [ __ ] cpa that has a degree on
of a master's degree i could go i could
pay for whatever the [ __ ] you need to
talk about he was prom king at bay city
high school
give it up for nelly and cassandra
they went on a date
no he is
we're out of time sorry
we got noey and what's your name
katie from bay city
the king and queen of bay city
they got all their teeth
this is the uh
this is the prom
yeah
i
i
i hated that
first of all because i've gotten the
most free stuff
in my whole life with this hair so your
hair looks great i don't know i know it
does i'm just
i can't fathom what just happened
yeah i can't i've tripped on acid a lot
and that was worse than all of my trips
yeah his pacing was a little weird
yeah
he's an interesting dude you know
it's
like he has to live like that
like his whole life is like that
i know i want to fight people now let's
go
anyone want to box they'll say she'll be
up here
uh anything you want to say to these
fine folks um i have a show at green jay
on the 25th call of shameless
check check her out and green jay you
are not invited
she's on instagram
at dulce mac
check her out my name is hans kim thank
you guys so much
there's an open mic after this
thank you bye
[Applause]
[Music]